let's see so it's gonna be nightmare
versus the yo man Yoshimitsu possibly
possibly but for the most part of me he
does have quite the bag of characters
but he's been clutching it out with the
oshi for the most part at least today
yes at Raytheon who in my eyes right
it's every single person in the LCQ has
to be considered a Dark Horse right
because you just train a boy to fight it
because you didn't win the Dark Horse's
that is the single LCQ winner drapion
and tomahawk that the two guys to the
killer so it's not surprising that
they're here it wasn't everything you
thought it was gonna be as LCQ s always
going you don't it's this this ish is
not gonna go according to the bracket or
seating or a plan or whatever you
expected so if the nightmare train
continues on every soul he collects his
hair grows longer and longer eventually
he will be able to take over the world
but right now he's gonna have to take on
boom and boom has piquillo she men suit
the crowd cheering for boom I could hear
him but let's see how this plays out
again since we are now in our top eight
we got to remember this is two out of
three this is the loser side of the
bracket so if you are out and you lose
this set you are out of the tournament
at least at this point you would be
placing seventh year yeah secure
spectator bow oh yeah all right they've
got the thumbs up
raytheon doesn't even have enough
emotion to light
confirmed of what take it was like oh
that's what happens when you pick
nightmare that the night the terror and
the big so she meets all right any
thoughts on the match up what do you
think the way we've been seeing
drapion play he is the kind of player
that has you know just clutched it out
timing again from what I've seen at
least he has calculated he has always
found the hits that he needed and he
really took control the matches when
they mattered yeah I feel like that's
like almost everybody that we've been
seeing getting it to this top eight he
was also one of those guys around the
dial that is come back protection and
ransack and somebody whoever is waving
the magic finger would have ever way the
wind blows right hopefully it was in his
way they're both gonna talk to set
things off is that is that the new
gentleman shakes a little bit of respect
in SoCal Road ice I respect that
I personally launchers nice magic are
fist into the attack follow-up and I
won't take you know a stroll through
nature sniffing both of those trees
back-to-back as those wall couples add
it up or not that was an exceptionally
quick round for pool
oh yeah that was a nice series of course
fighting back goes for the black Decker
they able to get anything out of it but
still oh the first in his face
Wow keeping it just one straight good
time I think drinking is looking to all
that was a creep on Easter respect for
your turn my turn whatever you want to
do it we can get crazy if you want to
but it's not necessarily what do these
do and right there what yeah yeah that's
I guess he didn't have the frames you
know they get a sufficient one is that
he wanted so you went with the big stuff
instead however a lot of work man
defensively but who was able to take you
to those two routes towards the very
edge everything still worked out of this
favorite this is where changes I think
that would be stacks of meter gonna
finally be able to get that positioning
let's see what he does here he's
whittling away at the light bar look at
it this is all block by the way yeah
that's it for this try to step out of
the way but honey believe a to kick big
comeback potential no doesn't use any of
the meter there was a six cage filled in
the brave edge all right one more he
could do it oh the low swipe JP on on
the scoreboard now two routes to one
okay catches it right out of the air
Pogo cheese look at the sequence right
now get him with the smart stuff get off
me they both are in sole charge state
that's okay pools gonna get that strike
doesn't quite get the wall but this is
so much damage either way so which are
just giving you that extra layer oh it's
still hitting offensive prowess of
course it is everything is going good
for the backboard nothing but net from
behind how about this launch ooh look at
this almost caught him on the follow
button standing a little close up boom
with the first boom of the match yeah
great reaction there he wasn't gonna
wait for the follow-up don't fix up for
you buddy I saw that claw you go ahead
and you can touch the mats but you can't
tear it off you got to respect the
legacy all right so that's three a
coming out just as a check like biking
rematch again caught him moving at the
start - a break attack what is God what
an 88 to the face of staff have Zack
stand up talk to me like a man all right
I got to BP up close and personal
a little CQC going on and a duck great
reaction and a fantastic closure to that
round they're leaving though stone
unturned JP young Fleming ouch anyway
he's a fantastic oh no boom got it last
time but fantastic and quick round one
like what I'm seeing here not face you
know after losing that tough person
match he is not afraid from sticking to
the game plan
okay sites oh he gets on as well I love
Joe sees everything
having it's in his name it makes you go
yo all right get some here with a
extension or pushing towards the edge of
the ring he should have let it go
probably would have got him closer to
the wall but look at this tied up that's
something he has to think about he has
to do so now two rounds away from defeat
and elimination yeah don't play with the
teleport if you're gonna do it go ahead
because baby I'm not gonna let you hit
me with anything
Wow 88 coming through talk to me I'm
here to a plus B charge it up down oh
the nice step they're able to get this
back but not able to capitalize damage
one just unfortunate situation there
boom continued on with the shrinking
that pulled of just out of the range for
that particular punishment and I like
the idea of the REE there JP had a
chance but instead he's just gonna take
it in the old RPS style I got you both I
know exactly where you are gonna be
for the pork a series not able to get
anything afterwards now double so let's
see who they're whittling away they're
gonna have to utilize some of this oh my
gosh that would sink stand up absurd
mark man do it again do it again
oh man into the oh my gosh what a
sequence here comes boom boom is
threatening now now run-up soul charge
okay let's do it that's white one one
time let's do another the BART meter got
caught just by the side of that sword
very unsecure oh my god he ate that see
habit and he can't close it out boom
what's happening he's gonna have to be
careful oh my god she's a standing be
able to take it but you saw that
sequence he thought he had it
oh my god he had over a wife left he
better ask for all the forgiveness in
that situation straightening out holding
onto the bar now walking into the final
round with two bars and feet are gonna
crack one immediately for the sole
charge at the step kick to check those
knees look at it again caught him that's
gonna hit picking all the right Oki gear
boom it's gonna stand up properly this
time just want to do any of the extra
however he has another
another opportunity here let's see if
Lube is able to do anything either
down to the wire sharing held values in
this situation you attack I attack
knock down making a wall to GI those
flying and then to follow up duct tape
down with the reed he knew and boom
trying to hop on the pole go put the
swift kick for Kate to the face sit down
let me relax one game apiece I think he
can't tell but I think I can't tying it
up back and forth drapion on this four
part now boom had a crazy flurry of just
brilliance back and forth towards the
end of all of these rounds but not able
to close it out throwing them toss them
towards the log that's gonna give the
follow-up what's you to do ooh that was
a pretty quick round that was a message
that's what it felt like I got you check
this out continue with the trend of
exceptionally fast first rounds in this
set
there you go fight it back fire with
fire now getting a throw trying to
return the damage that was done to him
in the first round before insurance
policy say okay this is what you owe now
write all the time carrying up to the
wall here's the reversal edge oh look at
that and hate we're tied up I think it's
the worst way to lose are you
straight-up get called out with a
movement yeah like I knew exactly what
you can do things thanks for playing
I packed two backgrounds it would be
high drama if it wasn't the same
sequence throughout the tournament and
whoa like it out his last game is just
gonna be emphatic
just exclamation points all across the
board
he does have oh man he's using it he's
gonna get the wall here that's done
look at that drapion that one round away
that's gonna give boom pretty much full
meter here training rounds back to back
you just love to see it what happens in
this situation put instead gonna keep
his safe home not gonna alter his
gameplay at all smart stuff up and you
down no matter what same because of that
he's able to approach
oh great stuff that was smart able to
keep the pressure off of them more than
half of his full charge already used
still try to keep that pressure put a GI
going the other way keeping it safe
they're not looking for a Ricci is into
which you've already got plus little
prick attack last time it's a lethal hit
runs in the game better positioning run
throught any points unnecessary at this
point just playing the screen game now
try not to get caught by any of these
watch out here oh he gets them that's
the tip definitely not the situation
goals in the sole charge dogs over it I
like the idea put it a little bit too
much time in the air nice tuck to go
under and yet he had to so charger yeah
so much smart coming out big brains from
the polls of these pits and that's a
mark fair we are going to the final game
final round but there is gonna be a
disadvantage here meter wise for who so
he's gonna have to deal with at least a
few big subs coming in from nightmare
drapion though let's see what he doesn't
it how is he gonna utilize it here the
matchup gets a big launch this is very
fortunate for Theon to get a life leave
before he even has a rely on
the offensive setting instead let it
know it's booms
whatever is left in the tank easy right
now - way to slow down that bullsh you
didn't want to deal with else we'd give
up here comes the sweet oh yeah that's
it put a stop to it stop it very scary
chip damage so much
oh my guess he hasn't know me mr.
follow-up unfortunate situation it's go
time no he does it oh this is huge one
makes up in a tree mark man what's gonna
do staying alive life is very very good
on the accelerate gaming side of things
right now and pull just enough theater
to get the extension on that final
sequence this man my god playing with
fire yeah you better make that face cuz
yeah that's my point with fire the whole
sim gotta give it up for tres young
though I'm very strong finish here
seventh place but really showing the
people man that he has quite the night
next pit fire he dies in - you don't
want to play right down to this can they
play yeah I got yeah we got you don't be
talking about earlier but like you know
stamina and like you know getting burned
down I feel like that pop off he's
probably sent him he's probably gonna be
tired after that never knows so coming
up next he will in fact get a break but
not you not us